Welcome to Lesson 11. In Lesson 10, you learned about dependent samples or
repeated measures. Just to refresh your memory, that could be where we give the
same person two different conditions to see how they react to each one. Maybe a
control and then a treatment, or maybe two types of treatments. Or, this could
be longitudinal, where we measure some variable at some point in time, and then
again at another and see if the variable changes. Or this could be a pre-test
and post-test. What was the measurement of a variable before and after a
treatment? These are just a few situations in which we would use dependent
samples. This type of research design is really useful because it controls for
indivdual differences. In other words, if we gave someone some kind of
treatment, then those same individual differences will be present the next time
we give that same treatment. That way we can see how two different treatments
play out under the same conditions. Because there's controls for individual
differeneces, we could then use fewer subjects. And this is more cost
effective, less time consuming, and generally less expensive. However, there
are also a few disadvantages. One of which, is carry-over effects. For example,
let's say we have this new method of teaching math. You want to know if it's
going to be effective. If you use the same group of students to test this new
teaching method, inevitably, they're going to be better at math the second time
around. So, if the first time we teach them one way, and then the second lesson
we teach them a different way, they'll already be better at math from learning
it the first time. Then we don't know if the results after the second treatment
are due to the fact that it was effective or due to the fact that they've
learned math before. That's just one example. The second measurement can be
affected by the first treatment. And the order in which we give the treatment
might influence the results. For example, say we want to test two types of
pills. What if the first pill has some kind of interaction with the second
pill? And so, by taking it in that order they affect the results. Therefore, in
this lesson, you're going to learn about independent samples. Whereas,
dependent samples deals with within subject designs, independent samples deals
with between subject designs. In this case, the advantages of dependent samples
are the disadvantages of independent samples. And the disadvantages of
dependent samples are the advantages of independent samples. Does that make
sense? With independent samples, we need more subjects because we need to
randomize the two groups taking the two treatments. We need a larger end to
control for individual differences as best as possible. That means it's more
time consuming and generally more expensive. But then the advantages of
independent samples are that we don't have carry over effects. Therefore, we
can give one treatment to one group, another treatment to another group, and
not worry about one treatment effecting the other, because each person or each
subject only gets one treatment. With independent samples, we can do an
experimental test where we give treatments to the subjects. Or observational,
where we simply observe characteristics of two different populations, and then
compare them. Everything is exactly the same. The Null and Alternative
Hypotheses, the t-statistic, and the way we make our statistical decision.